- I appreciate y'all coming
and have a conversation.
- There's a lot we do within the building
to create spaces that are
conducive for de-escalation.
Kids are able to remove themselves
from a negative situation,
process what has caused the crisis,
and make different choices
about how to move forward.
- Sometimes it's not the
easiest thing in the world
to tell a kid, "I know all
this is happening to you.
"I know all of this is going on,
"but I want you to learn."
And so we are giving them a space
and a context to process
some of that emotion,
to de-escalate, and then
transition back to class.
- Many of our classrooms
have what we call de-escalation spaces,
so they'll be a bean bag in the corner
or a curtain that allows you to step away.
Just something that creates
a little bit of separation
for kids that the teacher
recognizes need that
or the student.
- [Woman] Here she comes.
- [Tanzye] Hi how are you?
- [Mary] I'm decent.
- Students come to me, I greet them,
and then I just give them alone time.
Because I don't associate
the space necessarily
with academics, it's easier
for them to utilize it
outside of the classroom and
recognize it as a safe space.
For myself when my emotions are high,
it's best to calm down before
I begin to try to communicate.
- It's giving us a time to
cool down, do the coloring.
It gives me opportunity
to be like, "Okay yeah,
"take in this breath.
"I can talk now without trying to cry."
Just letting us do that makes it better.
- [Tanzye] So then they'll begin to share
and open up about what's bothering them.
How was that?
- It wasn't good.
- [Tanzye] We really try to teach our kids
how to be resilient, how
to utilize resources,
and take care of themselves.
We have another space where
our counselor's located.
- All right, so you're gonna talk first.
And when he get done,
you're gonna talk, okay?
- [Tanzye] Who does real
time conflict resolution.
- I didn't wanna tell
you who to hang with.
- [Tanzye] We can't expect
people to just get along,
we have to show them what
getting along looks like.
- You have an issue with a teacher,
with another student, they come to my room
and we have a conversation
like, "Hey, what happened?"
Today I had two students.
They've been friends for
about two or three years.
They had a big old fight with another boy.
We stopped 'em outside,
and we brought 'em in.
Both are strong young men.
- What is going to happen,
is knowing how I contributed
to the conflict, right?
And how to respond to you with empathy.
- I wasn't solving it out the right way.
I should've communicated better.
- We come to the table and
say, "Hey, it aint about you.
"It's about respect each other."
Y'all go ahead and go back
to class, and that's it.
Anything happen, I'm
come back here, alright?
- We took it upon ourself
to go have a conversation
with the other gentlemen that was arguing,
and then that's when we
got everything solved.
- When we have de-escalation spaces
where we're teaching them
to manage themselves,
then we make it so they
can be successful anywhere.
Saying just power through
or white knuckle through
something, is not a strategy.
When you say, "I see you, I recognize you,
"and I'm gonna teach you
how to take that moment
"to walk away, recenter,
"and come back and do
what you need to do."
That's actually teaching
resilience and (mumbles).
- When I just feel like I'm
not doing something right,
and I just need a moment.